hey youtubers is Charlie so I finally
had a chance to see amazing spider-man 2
so I wanted to do a full review as well
as talk about the sinister six movies in
the spin-offs that they're developing
that's right they're developing their
own kind of spider-man movie universe
just like Marvel's doing so also talked
about the post-credits scene - if you're
finding me for the first time I do
regular movie reviews for all my
favorite sci-fi fantasy in John ray you
know comic book movies I even have a
Marvel day on Tuesday that's dedicated
just to Marvel and it's gonna be a Star
Wars day - so be sure to subscribe to
get everything
let's all dream of the day whenever
spider-man can rejoin the Avengers and
take his rightful place along with
Wolverine - so because there's so much
to get through I'm going to start with
my review the movie then I'll talk about
sinister six and then I'll talk about
that post-credit scene that x-men
post-credits scene careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the movie yet but
here we go starting off with things that
I really loved about the movie the
actors
yes Andrew Garfield and Emma Stone are
the leads but I want to give some
special attention to Jamie Foxx and Dane
DeHaan before I actually sat down to see
the movie I actually saw some funny
stuff on Twitter a lot of movie critics
were actually calling it the best Batman
Forever reboot ever they were just
comparing Jim Carrey's Riddler character
to Jamie Foxx and you know Tommy Lee
Jones emo two-face - Dane DeHaan it's
not meant to make fun of them it's just
a funny meta way to think about their
performances Jamie Foxx is actually one
of the best comedic character actors out
there the reason he ended up being in
Django Unchained was actually because
Will Smith did not want to play a slave
Jamie Foxx on the other hand is pretty
fearless whenever it comes to putting
himself into characters and he's not
typecast like a lot of other a-list
actors so he gets to have a lot more fun
ala electro and sinister six when I see
big movies like this that cast you know
big actors like Jamie Foxx I try to
guess which scenes they use to pitch the
movie to them and I feel like it was
that scene where he was in an apartment
by himself you know with the birthday
cake just talking to himself being silly
that was like a perfect when I play
Jamie Foxx could perform that on
Broadway and it would be amazing that's
the scene where you learn everything you
need to know about his character his
tics the way he perceives himself and
the way he thinks about everyone else it
was definitely one of my favorite non
action scenes you know just him being
crazy talking to himself I really did
like Jamie Foxx's max Dylan character
better than the elect
character I don't think we'll see him
again the electro persona is basically
taken over by the end of the movie but
let's talk about Dane DeHaan now just
like Jamie Foxx I really like Dane
DeHaan Harry Osborne character more than
I liked the Green Goblin character I
feel like that boardroom scene that he
had was actually his best in the movie
we didn't really get as much time with
him pre transformation as we did with
Jamie Foxx's character I would have
liked more scenes like that boardroom
scene everyone in this room now works
for Felicia
I feel like enough time has passed that
going into this a lot of people weren't
really thinking about James Franco's you
know college dropout version of Harry I
really think Dane DeHaan version of the
character is much more interesting he
does have the benefit of being a genius
this time around I'm not entirely sure
why Norman Osborn said he was wasting
his potential but I think it had
something to do with him traveling
around the world dating supermodels
after school my only real disappointment
with him was that the Oscorp executive
became a fourth villain I don't know
about you guys but I felt like it would
have been a lot more fun to see an evil
Dark Knight version of Harry Osborn like
a diametric opposite to Christian Bale's
Batman you know in that scenario he
would just you know seize control of
Oscorp and use his funds and technology
to fund a private war against
superheroes he did get fired from the
Oscorp board but I think he still owns
the company so he's still super-rich
they're just trying to lock him out of
the building and I don't know how the
sequel's will treat that because of the
end he's locked up at Ravencroft as for
the other main characters I always loved
Emma Stone and everything she does and
given the fact that they pretty much
spoiled what was going to happen to her
character in the movie
there weren't any big surprises I do
like that her version of gwen stacy got
to be a critical part of the solution
but I still feel like she was wasted and
that ends up happening to a lot of great
actors you know they get buried under
these giant movies it was a lot like
what happened to Scarlett Johansson and
Avengers I feel like Winter Soldier
corrected that problem though it was
actually a really good example of a big
comic book movie that gave an equal role
to the female lead so I feel like Sony
could learn a lot from that we did get
to meet Felicia Hardy even though she
was almost not even in the movie I feel
like she's gonna get an expanded you
know black cat role in the sequels in
case you don't remember a couple of
months ago shailene woodley was also
playing Mary Jane Watson
they shot scenes with her and everything
but she ended up getting cut out of the
movie and now that we've all seen it
hopefully it's easy to understand why
the store
is just trying to do so many things I'm
glad they didn't include more characters
it would have been like spider-man 3 all
over again
so let's talk about the story now there
were a couple things that I really
enjoyed and just a few things that I had
issues with right off the bat going into
movies like this I try to remind myself
that they're not made for me remember
that little kid in the spider-man
pajamas at the end of the movie that's
who this movie was made for it was made
for little kids if you watch it with
that in mind I feel like you'll enjoy
yourself a lot more so don't expect this
to be like Dark Knight hard-r or
anything like that I love that they're
trying to be so ambitious with this
spider-man movie universe they're trying
to create and I feel like you know
Oscorp special projects and Ravencroft
did that pretty effectively during the
movie so we even actually know who that
lineup is for sinister 6 I feel like
those two things were actually the whole
movie you know you could have just
called it amazing spider-man 2 rise of
the sinister six and nothing would have
changed I am actually looking forward to
the spin-offs but remember those movies
are also going to be written for little
kids in spider-man pajamas the only real
issue that I had with the story was the
amount of time that they spent dedicated
to non-essential characters like
spider-man helping that little kid with
the windmill that scene was there
because obviously this is a movie for
little kids but the only other thing
that made me feel very tired were the
jokes I feel like trying to do silly
spider-man humour with Sam Raimi's thing
and he was a master of that kind of
humor in the first trilogy but because
that was something that so many people
responded to I felt like the producers
were really quick to try and force that
into the Andrew Garfield reboot but I'm
just not a big fan of silly Andrew
Garfield I think he does a lot better
whenever he's doing drama so let's talk
a little bit about the action in that
camerawork there were some things that I
really liked they did make some really
good improvements to the first person
camera you know whenever you're swinging
around with spider-man like the opening
scene of the movie that was a lot of fun
the action scenes were also pretty good
but Andrew Garfield is a dramatic actor
not an action hero you know he's not
Chris Hemsworth and he doesn't quite
have the balance of ridiculousness and
sincerity that Robert Downey jr. has at
least yet he'll get there eventually you
know he's a great actor so I'm really
interested to see what the sequels look
like but now it's your turn let me know
what you thought about the movie and did
you like the way they set up the sequels
and spin-offs movies you know do you
think that they can create a spider-man
movie universe without things getting
too ridiculous right now they've already
confirmed
spider-man three and four along with
sinister six and a venom movie the next
spider-verse movie will probably be that
third sequel they're supposed to start
production on sinister six early in 2015
so that might not be doubt until late
2016 or spring 2017 the venom movie
isn't supposed to be happening until
around spider-man 4 so that'll probably
be even further along so let's talk a
little bit about what that sinister six
movie is going to be like as well as
that x-men post-credit scene in case you
missed it during the credits of the
movie whenever that song was playing
they showed all the Oscorp tech from
secret projects like the Doctor Octopus
harness and the Green Goblin glider
they're basically who the lineup is for
sinister six the movie
it's Green Goblin Doctor Octopus Rhino
vulture Kraven the hunter and Mysterio
or it could also be the chameleon but I
think Mysterio would be a lot more fun
and based on that Ravencroft scene at
the end I think they'll just be
targeting prisoners that are on death
row or just people looking for a quick
rabbit power but they will probably
stick with the original comic book
characters to become those villains I'm
choosing to remain optimistic about all
those movies since the reboots have
started they've cast great actors but a
lot of it will just depend on whatever
the scripts look like which we won't see
for a long time but let me know if
you're excited to see sinister 6 and
these other spin-off movies so now let's
move on to that x-men post-credit scene
if you're not familiar sony is
spider-man x-men is Fox so there's no
connection between those two universes
on a story level x-men has nothing to do
with spider-man
the reason they included that scene at
the end of the movie was all because of
the director Marc Webb he had a contract
that was still in force at Fox whenever
Sony hired him to direct amazing
spider-man Fox agreed to let him out of
his contract but Sony had to agree to
promote Days of Future past also because
Sony did not have any post credits
scenes of their own for these other
spider-man's spin-offs they were really
happy to have something to play at the
end of the movie a lot of people feel
like nowadays if you don't get a
post-credits scene after a big comic
book movie like this you're kind of
cheated out of your money the x-men
scene really didn't have anything
spoilery in it it just establishes that
mystique is operating on her own and all
the scenes we've seen so far Magneto and
Professor X are on their own without the
teams so this just helps set that up a
little bit more let me know whether you
thought it felt out of place though
I mean x-men has nothing to do with
spider-man so it was a little out of
context but in related news next week
I'm starting a special Godzilla week
with Nerdist channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I'm just going to be doing fun bonus
videos for Godzilla because that movie
is coming out in two weeks I'm not going
to be posting my review though till it
actually is released right now click
here to get my breakdown of Star Wars
Episode seven and click here to learn
more about the Justice League movie
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you tomorrow
high fives
[Music]